même dans son dernier titre le pire tu
t'engages pour la planète
tu parles des dérives du monde actuel on
voit dans ton clip comme on l'a vu tout
à l'heure des poissons des chevaux des
dauphins et ça nous a donné une idée
en fait j'ai demandé à chaque
chroniqueur de réfléchir à quel animal
et en lui nous dire pourquoi ce choix
ou est-ce que voilà m ghinzu est-ce que
vous vous sentez que vous avez un animal
en vous vous voulez pour l'assemblée
vous c'est qui l'animal bas je suis en
coque
parce que oui d'abord le coq et
bisexuels ça va très peu personne de sa
wii solidement mamie pourra confirmer et
en plus sage c'est l'emblème
ah oui par rapport aux fans ce par
rapport aux de leurs moeurs de même
cette émission ou poursuite est vrai que
les gens me disent souvent tu es un
emblème et donc je suis de coke
d'accord c'est que ça n'annule pas
chanter sur un tas de fumier
non c'est moi qu'on les vacances à très
bas avec ce qu'on va montrer demain sur
la laponie en prime alors qu'abbas calmé
pendant quinze jours en laponie et n'a
pas connu que des règles meddahi bout
moi j'ai dire dauphin ce que ça sourit
tout le temps mais faut pas faire chier
ah ouais mais je vais faire
caméléon avril que voilà je m'adapte
partout j'ai l'habitude de la du monde
de la nuit je suis aux couleurs de des
chats des chiens de plus non non mais si
oui vous hamster pourquoi donc quand je
trouve quelque chose je ne lâche pas
jusqu'à ce que j'aie la vérité voilà on
va vous lâchez nous bientôt vous allez
au bout mais ce que vous dites tellement
souvent que c'est une vieille chouette
que comme ça au moins on en famille quoi
en chatte à auch attractive quoi alors
regardez moi je vois là parlant de chats
parce que les dynamos dessus et ça
cartonne tout le temps d'une vidéo de
chat qui aide à faire le ménage regarder
ses bluffs sans regarder ces bleus
kkr
[Applaudissements]
parce que je sais qu'on va voir la vidéo
qui me fait le plus gris mais du monde
entier vous êtes en quoi moi c'est une
évidence un simple c'est ce que j'ai
fait et en fait j'ai oublié de passer la
vidéo du singe ce n'est pas du sang
froid mais je m'en lasse le galop est-ce
que vous avez vu cette vidéo de ceux qui
n'en sont kaka allait se régler mais je
peux la voir une fois je sais que je
vais rigoler regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu ne la connaissais pas alors on peut
la voir faire cela tout petits de la fad
tu fan absolu franchement bravo et vive
la france
voilà bon bah merci gens pètent j'ai
fait juste ce tour de table je préfère
vous dire franchement